foreign
[Music]
how would you rate it and my answer was
a 15.
[Music]
the professors from day one what I was
struck with was how real and how
relatable they were no barrier
it is a lot of connections that can help
you think through what you're going to
do next the amount of takeaways I've
gotten from the other people talking
about the things we've learned and given
this just as much as the sessions
themselves
I returned to work with so much more
energy and positivity I'm excited
because I think it's going to make me a
better leader you just feel like hey I'm
ready ready to take on any challenge
without any fear adding all those
elements into the program make this
really life-changing
your job is to come here not because you
know what's next
but because you want to design a future
of discovery
[Music]